[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كثير من الرجال والشباب بيستمتعوا بتدخين
السيجاره والهم طقوسم الخاصه اثناء
التدخينه ولكن اللي ما بيعرفوه انه
السيجار اله اثار جانبيه جدا سيئه وما
بتختصر بس على الجهاز التنفسي والرئتين
من اهم الاثار السلبيه اللي بتنتج عن
تدخين السيجار هي اصفرار الاسنان وتصبغها
اضافه الى الافات السرطانيه وما قبل
السرطانيه اللي ممكن انها تصيب اللثه
والشفاء واللسان
[موسيقى]
اضافه الى الاثار السلبيه المرضيه لاسيجار
هناك اثار تجميليه تكمن في تلون اللثه
والشفاء
الحل الوحيد لتفادي اضرار السيجاره هو
الامتناع عن التدخين نهائيا ولكن ممكن
التخفيف من اضراره من خلال التدخين
الانواع الخفيفه نوعا ما من السيجار وكمان
اعتماد شرب الماء مباشره بعد الانتهاء من
التدخين
[موسيقى]
علاج الامراض الناتجه عن تسخين السيجار
بيكون على مرحلتين المرحله الاولى اذا
المشاكل كانت تجميليه فقط باستخدام الليزر
لتفتيح الشفاه او اللثه المرحله الثانيه
بتكون اذا وصلنا للافات السرطانيه او ما
قبل السرطانيه من خلال الاستئصال الجراحي
سواء من خلال الجراحه التقليديه او جراحه
باستخدام الليزر